welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Wheel of Time season one our Story
begins in the quaint little village of
Two Rivers where we follow a group of
five young friends there's Rand the
shepherd Perrin the blacksmith and Matt
the degenerate Gambler Thief iguane has
just come of age and gotten her classic
Two Rivers braid and just a few years
older is naive The Village wisdom like
the Medicine Woman and she's hoping to
take a guineas and Apprentice because
they can do a little bit of magic but
tonight the two rivers gets a visit from
a woman Moraine who is a real wizard in
this world they call an eyes to die they
don't call it magic they call it
channeling the one power and the I said
I the official group of sorceresses are
respected and feared now this world
thinks of time not linearly but as The
Wheel of Time because it's all about
cycles and reincarnation Moraine is
following up on a prophecy that a
youngster from this Village would be a
Reincarnation of a legendary figure the
dragon reborn problem is all five of
them could fit the prophecy and it's
clear they're all tavirum people that
are super important to fate now
tonight's a big festival at the two
rivers so The Peddler Pat in vain comes
to town more on him later and everyone's
having a great time until party crashers
arrive oh yeah it's the trollux these
like Minotaur monsters luckily there's
an iced eye here to blast them all with
some magic and moraine's traveling with
her Warner land who's a great warrior
there to watch her back a trollock
busted into rand's house but Ran's Dad
pulls out his sword from under the bed
and oh he's no normal Shepherd he's a
master swordsman Perrin grabs an ax he
and his wife are fighting trolls
together but he goes into a frenzy and
oh it's her no killed his own wife
that's traumatizing in the end the
village is mostly saved except naive who
gets captured so Maureen fills these
kids in the dark one's hunting you cause
one of you is the dragon reborn so they
gotta go off on an adventure but the
trollets are hot on their tails so they
take shelter for a night in this old
ruined City that the trolls won't enter
cause it's cursed shotar logo the city
of Shadow don't worry we'll be fine as
long as no one touches anything but Matt
immediately grabs the obviously cursed
dagger so the shadow wakes up and now
it's hunted them everyone escapes but
they're all separated Rand and Matt make
it to a nearby Village where they
befriend the bartender but though she's
here to capture them yes she's a dark
friend a person who's working for The
Dark One in hopes of Eternal reward but
there's a Glee man in town a traveling
Bard and this one's Tom Marilyn an older
rocker type and he's a great knife
thrower saves these guys like let's get
out of here they see shelter at a nearby
Farmhouse but oh what's this the whole
family's been killed and maybe it was
mapped with his curse dagger but more
likely it was this Naz ghoul Voldemort
guy called a fade who are the dark ones
top lieutenants Tom Marilyn stays behind
to fight it so the boys can escape iguin
and parent are rescued by a traveling
people called the tuata on or more
commonly just the Tinkers they follow a
pacifist philosophy called The Way of
the leaf because even in self-defense
violence is always bad and this
resonates with Perrin who is still
traumatized by having accidentally
killed his own wife but now they have a
run-in with the children of the light we
met some before they're a religious
order like the Knights Templar committed
to doing good except The Inquisitor
Eamon valda who's a real bad dude
hunting down all eyes to die and like
keeping their rings as trophies he
recognizes a queen and parent as
suspicious characters so the Tinkers
stand up to defend them with no violence
which obviously doesn't work and they're
captured he thinks a gwain is a secret I
said I and indeed she can channel the
one power though she still needs some
training but Perrin has some unexpected
powers of his own as like a lot of
wolves have been hanging around him
lately and now his eyes turn yellow he
gets super strength and now a whole pack
of wolves attack the camp and they
escape meanwhile land and Moraine met up
with nine Eve Who's a huge badass and
managed to escape and she doesn't trust
anyone especially Moraine but Lane
convinces her they're on the same side
they meet up with some more I said I led
by moraine's rival liandrin and they've
just captured a man who could Channel
and claim to be the dragon reborn yes
the isidai are all women because the
male half of the one power was corrupted
by The Dark One any man who channels
goes insane and so the red eye said I
hunt down these men and still them
cutting them off from the power
permanently but that leaves them a shell
of a human being and regarding the
dragon reborn it's uncertain if they're
a hero or a villain the original Dragon
broke the world officialized to die
policy is snuff out any potential
dragons so Maureen's keeping her kids a
secret but this guy Logan is a real
powerful Channel or breaks free of his
cage and kills everyone in the room but
naive busted in and she's even stronger
unleashes a huge last of magic to heal
everyone and the rest of the eyes to die
are able to steal this guy so our groups
all separately make it to tarvalen the
big city in the area and home to the
iced Eyes White Tower and Moraine has to
report to the iced eyes leader the
amerlin seat and it's against the rules
that moraine's not telling anyone what
she's up to so publicly the amarlane sea
test chastiser but privately Moraine
goes to her room and these two are old
friends in fact they're lovers she and
Maureen are the only ones that know the
secret prophecy that the I said I aren't
supposed to fight the dragon reborn
they're supposed to fight with the
dragon are born to save the world but I
guess that info wouldn't be accepted so
they have to work behind the scenes so
the amberlin seat pulls out the
unbreakable bowel rod and banishes
Moraine from the White Tower but of
course that's exactly what they wanted
so Moraine can continue her Quest the
dark one is escaping his prison at the
eye of the world and so whichever one of
you is the dragon has to go there and
strengthen the seal and they can get
there real fast by traveling through the
magic door but wait what's this Matt is
staying behind yes he's been getting
progressively more cursed and finally
Maureen was able to get that curse out
of him put it back in the dagger but
he's still not feeling this whole
Adventure so he's just gonna stay behind
now the ways are an ancient magic
pathway built by the ogear a race of
nature people who live a long time so
move real slow this one loyal is
traveling with them to help them
navigate but it's all been corrupted the
dark ones moving his trolleys through
here and worse than trollix is Machin
Shin the black wind that like uh
Whispers all your worst fears into your
head but naive resists it through the
power of stubbornness and holds this
thing back so they can all Escape
they're at the Fortress city of faldara
in the Borderlands that guard the world
from the blight Beyond incidentally this
is Lan's Hometown in fact he's land man
Dragon heir to the throne of a kingdom
that was lost to the blight many years
ago land is the strong silent type and
na needs the standoffish type so these
two Get It On by the way Rand and aguan
are a long-standing couple but they've
been separated this whole time and now
they fight over nothing because Ran's
kind of whiny but he apologizes and they
get back together they're in love but
now Moraine gives the kids the bad news
at the dark ones prison whoever is not
the dragon will 100 die so Maureen
visits a bartender here named Min who
can read people's futures in hopes that
she can tell which one is the dragon she
says she can't tell by later while Rand
is doing some late tonight archery he
has an epiphany this whole time he's
been channeling the one power without
realizing so he goes to see Min who's
like yeah kid I know you I saw your
birth there's a race of Desert Warrior
people called The ayeel Who all have
pale skin and red hair like you do in
the desert this ideal Warrior was
fighting super pregnant and oh the
baby's coming right now she was found by
one of the enemy soldiers yeah that's
rand's Shepherd dad Tam althor his mom
died in childbirth so he took Rand home
to raise as his own so wait does that
mean I'm the dragon yeah I don't know I
probably so to save his friends he grabs
Moraine and the two of them go off alone
to venture through the blight but now
that rans close he gets a dream visit
from the dark one himself who's like hey
man I'm actually just a normal dude it's
like hey Dragon good to see you again
but he's pretty disappointed Rand
doesn't remember his past life but we
get to see a brief flashback to 3 000
years ago at the end of the last age
when the world was like a super Advanced
magical Utopia and the dragon was this
guy lose therein who was a male eyes to
die yeah back then the male part of the
power wasn't corrupted apparently him
sealing the dark one is what corrupted
it and then broke the world and so we
come to the dark ones prison at the eye
of the world his heels weak enough that
he can manifest here Maureen tries to
fight him but he's way too strong Stills
her immediately cuts her off from Magic
Rand falls into a vision coma where he
and Wayne are living a happy simple life
the dark ones like yeah man this can be
real all you have to do is free me
meanwhile the dark one's trollets are
invading valdara and long story short
the Army's totally wrecked so it's up to
the King's sister who's an eyes to die
and gathers up a guine and naive and any
woman who can Channel and they all work
together to do a big spell that blam
destroys the whole Army but there's a
good reason they didn't lead with that
because channeling that much power Burns
you up and kills you but naive is
somehow able to take a queen's share of
the power herself to save a
guineaivedais over in Dreamland Rand
looks like he's gonna take the dark ones
deal but wait what's this psych bro yeah
I'm gonna put you back in your prison
and the day is saved but the physical
seal is all cracked now which sure
doesn't seem like it was strengthened
and back at the Fort they were pulling
their Magic Eye item out of storage when
oh they're all killed by none other than
Pat and fame The Peddler from the
beginning yes he's a dark friend who's
been following them this whole time and
he's like yeah this ain't over we're
just getting started this series was 14
books so a season one comes to an end
Perrin grabs an ax but he's committed
now to the non-violent way of the leaf
and on his way out Pat and Vane grabbed
Matt's cursed dagger so watch out for
that Matt himself is just chilling back
in the city but the actor's been her
cast so he'll look different iguane is
morning naive's death but though she
manages to heal her somehow so actually
naive's fine and Randall Thor the dragon
reborn he's like wait now that I
channeled magic am I gonna go crazy and
Maureen's like yeah I mean probably so
to save his friends from himself he's
like tell them I died here and rans
going off on his own to just be on his
own and there's a final teaser on the
other side of the continent that's now
facing an Invasion From A mysterious
power across the sea they use channelers
in Warfare to make a big Title Wave and
that's where Wheel of Time season one
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]